it has been more than a year of social
distancing and math squaring and
utilizing plexiglas but some of those
copic 19 protocols may go away
8 news now reporter victoria saha takes
a closer look tonight at 5. victoria
15 months ago being divided by a barrier
might have seemed ridiculous
but it was a way for employers to make
sure their employees
and their staff stayed safe and now as
coven 19
restrictions ease there's some mixed
feelings about the plexiglas
you see everywhere to keep the plexi
glass or to not
keep the plexiglas we're not as scared
about coronavirus now as we were a year
ago so
why not take them down at rachel's
kitchen the future of the plexiglas is
still
unknown you know i think it's just a
safety factor
just more for our team members than
anything else
for a busy eatery they're constantly
faced with people who may or may not be
sick
you know the public has become very
comfortable now walking around without
their mask especially with all the
changes that are being done
so it won't hurt them to have the
plexiglas continue shielding them from
any potential risks
the owner of rachel's kitchen says they
might take the plexiglass down
once most of her employees are fully
vaccinated i mean i'm ok with them
staying up as more people get their
vaccines though we can start taking them
down but
the fact that they have them is great it
helps help stop the spread but it seems
like what was once abnormal
has now become the norm you know i mean
i might be a little nervous but i'm very
healthy i am vaccinated
so i'm not too panicked at this point of
the game
now i did speak with a local company
that does make plexiglasses they say
businesses if you are trying to take
them down make sure you store them
somewhere safe
for a couple months reporting live from
the newsroom victoria zaha 8 news now
victoria thank you so we asked on
twitter do you think businesses should
be taking down those barriers or just
go ahead and leave them up 69 percent
say remove them
when appropriate and 31 percent say
leave them up indefinitely